- My name is Melanie Fox,
I create the AP Macroeconomics
and AP Microeconomics
content for Khan Academy.
Well if you don't develop that mindset,
you say, "I can't overcome this barrier,"
you've just made that barrier
permanent for yourself.
So for me, because I
loved economics so much
it was just a way of finding
a way around those barriers
whether that was taking fewer classes
to give myself more time to concentrate
in the areas that I struggled with,
taking classes in the summer
where I could focus on
just one class at a time,
that helped me a lot to
get past those barriers.
The day I walked out of
my calculus one final exam
and I knew that I had aced it
and I don't think I had aced a
math class since fifth grade.
And that was just euphoric,
I remember...
I can even remember the price of gasoline
when I walked out of the
building after that exam
because it was just such a
vivid memory of, I did it,
I was finally able to overcome this.
It's okay to struggle.
It's probably better to
struggle than to not struggle
because if you can get through
things very, very easily,
when you hit that first barrier,
you don't know what to do,
and it's good to have the
experience to have hit a barrier
and find a way to push back that.